Elizabeth Hurley's opening up about her
serving Sarah co-star Matthew Perry
Sarah Moore
um no uh
the actress reveals why the actor was a
nightmare to work with amid his
addiction
will you get into that uh you get into a
place in your life where you're having a
problem and you either you know lie down
about it or step up to bat and
take your uh take your swing and that's
what I did in an interview with Yahoo
entertainment Elizabeth chats about her
time with Matthew on the set of their
2002 romantic comedy oh no Sarah Moore
you are hereby served for divorce
to force what smile no hang on wait wait
a minute you must have the wrong person
um you must be looking for different
sorrow more that's what they all say
Matthew has to present me divorce papers
he's our process server and um once he
gives them to me I persuade him that
instead of giving him to me we should go
down to Texas and track down my horrible
husband I have to service Elizabeth
apparently and they're paying me to do
it so it's uh it's quite an easy gig and
in Matthew's new Memoir friends lovers
and the big terrible thing he wrote
about the production getting shut down
for two months so he could go to rehab
which Elizabeth says was difficult quote
I have very fond memories of him to be
honest it was a nightmare working with
him at that time and as it's now known
our movie was shut down because of his
addiction we were in a Force Major and
had to sit at home twiddling our thumbs
for some time she notes that though it
was a little tough to experience the
delays her co-star was fabulous when he
returned to the set am I hearing waves
sending me the fireworks
no waves
Elizabeth says quote obviously he was
having a tough time but he was still
very charming and a lovely person to
work with but you could see he was
suffering for sure it was a lot of fun
and uh you know we're very happy with
the movie and although Elizabeth admits
she's only read excerpts of Matthew's
book she has nothing but nice words to
say about it he's a very funny writer
like he's a very funny man he's an
incredibly gifted comedian his way with
words is fantastic
foreign
[Music]